[Musique]
ah ça bien passé sincèrement grâce à
tous les bénévoles est mâtiné premières
vont évidemment michael qu'à travers mes
premières et aux dents longues
yola ce bâtiment qui a préparé les les
joujoux bassimon arabes unis prenant les
associations et elle nous a parlé line
au moins quinze associations qu'ils
avaient récupéré des joujoux nous
avaient supplié passé mais le cadeau et
les 4500 que nous trappe et et moi pedro
que c'est en fait la belle très belle
opération et nous faire bizarre
[Musique]
oui nous faisons chaque soir courir pour
demander un don à les
parents qui ne peuvent pas acheter le
cadeau plaisante martine pugnace et déjà
des repères ne l'a pas pour nous de nous
remettre 51 cadeaux pour les enfants
donc je pense que ces manifestations
seraient très réussie avait peu goûté
une première où il était le cadeau qui
seront distribués cran c'est difficile
pour les associations de trouver des
cadeaux les subventions des aides très
difficile
c'est difficile parce que cette année
tous que jamais les canons augmenter
encore donc nous avons quand même
énormément d'enfants et ça nous aide
beaucoup d'avoir dit non
et c'est pas là des petits journaux
bonheur où nous des belles cadeaux bah
c'est mal acquis quelques temps les
aurait frappées cadiot
[Musique]